All right.
Let’s watch it.
Hopefully I am not horribly wrong.
Derek is giggling to himself right now.
>> Ok, you have made your prediction.
Now it is time to find out which block went
higher, the one that is shot off center or
the one that is shot right into the center
of mass.
Ok, we are just getting set for shooting straight
into the block.
How are you feeling about this one, Dave?
>> I think this is the one.
I really do.
>> Ok.
Range is going hot.
In three, two, one.
>> We have moved this block so now the gun
is actually firing into the right side of
the block.
So presumably one imagines that the block
will spin anticlockwise.
>> Three, two, one.
>> Now check out the high speed footage.
You can clearly see that both blocks go to
the exact same height, even though one is
rotating.
And that is a bit strange, because they were
both hit by the same type of bullet from the
same rifle, so presumably it had the same
kinetic energy.
And they both go the same height so they both
have the same gravitational potential energy,
but one is rotating.
And so it has that additional rotational energy.
So one block has more energy than the other
block.
>> I don’t know if I buy that, Dr. Muller.
>> Talk to me.
>> Yeah, I mean so you are telling me you
just created energy.
>> Not necessarily created energy.
So what are you thinking there?
>> I am potentially surprised.
>> Shoot at the same height?
>> Obviously I am wrong.
>> I think went up to the same height, which
is incredibly confusing to me.
>> Why is that confusing?
>> Because that doesn’t... where is that
extra energy coming from?
>> Well, the fact is that one block clearly
does have more energy.
You think about them both at the top, one
is spinning, one is not.
They basically have identical gravitational
energy, but one does have additional rotational
energy.
>> How is that possible and why is it happening?
>> No.
Explain it to me.
>> I don’t want to give you the answer right
away.
>> I love it when you say that.
I don’t want to give you the answer.
That means you don’t know.
I love that.
>> So if you can make me a video response,
I would love that.
Or if you just want to post your idea in the
comments below, that would be great.
And I will reveal the correct answer next
week.
So subscribe to the channel if you haven’t
already and you will find out in a week’s
time.
>> After I have time to pore over the footage
and consult a very smart man in the subject.
That is what you didn’t say.